all right welcome to this video was
owned final time I haven't done those
for a while and I'm not so sure hey I'll
um should do it now because it's still
no hey it's the frame hot here but I'm
alright so a quick one it's so
absolutely amazingly hot in Germany here
and I feel like my brain is melting down
so let's see what happens and once in a
while yeah you hear water noises that me
getting some water alright so our a team
which should up the move water here bit
in a French I actually didn't click the
doubling but oh no II resigns okay yeah
this guy actually has got three games
played of course no drama in this fun he
offers a draw and then place the ovens
funny mm-hmm okay so let's just grab the
spawn
okay so maybe you will can take c4 f3
knight takes maybe still those fields we
had for black I don't know just move the
booth of Bishop to see three in might
have we can do this 93 23 9 f wanna take
on g4 the night cannot escape and if you
move the bishop now I'll play you for
with tempo the cost a bit of time okay
well go to e3 I don't like that too much
all right
you need to make use of the rukon f1
this is all a bit term a bit shaky this
position yeah well it's not exactly
great against a completely [ __ ]
opening like the Alvin's but ok now
threatening mate and t7 is hanging so on
what should I do now just take d7 I can
also give the check which isn't bad
let's give the check
and all I should have taken f6 97 would
have been better really
yeah this is some just a pawn down for
pretty much nothing gary is doing all he
can to spoil it
all right I didn't have any time to talk
to do comments on this here yeah I
simply murdered himself after a while
alright so before you five scotch game
that looks fairly solid for black have
proper development and yeah don't know
this double porn shouldn't be a problem
no no should I play this or should be
six yeah just develop if he takes um I
don't mod ready with the two bishops
should be a should be okay want to play
out d5 opening the position up for the
two bishops hmm
you know I know just just retreat what
is he doing now with those pieces on the
default I was thinking about some
complicated stuff nitey form okay I'll
take it it's just a couple of checks cap
take this also two pieces to bishops
even yeah it's not resigning would be
nice i have a quikr win but that's quite
a lot of stuff on f 2 and now g two this
is three pieces yeah what now letting
the clock run down no yeah and that's
definitely not stalemate it still Scott
far too many ponds Andrew cage to mate
um yeah all right and look at all mate
yeah for the for the lead okay let's try
the Smith more I again oops yeah this is
nice just start three eggs or tempe or
something okay let's develop quickly how
does he protect our seven now not at all
alright yeah ok let's play a reversed
kind of set up here hmm okay yeah I was
close to being able to take on f2 but
let's try to open up quickly okay so
I'll take it now preventing them both
long and short castling with this bishop
okay i want to play tonight on oh my god
Bishop to h3 ok might intend Queen to h5
so play here take all the squares news
king when I can just take care right now
this or queen of atl Queen f8 was also
rather strong
um yeah take care right yet yeah I
removes wedding really this also okay
the screw care for was quite effective
Oh bitmap you just checked to me right
before the tournament let's mix it up
play with some London system not the
most aggressive opening but you can play
it quickly and there's still a little
bit of bite to it yeah this position for
example why till seven is a bit better
so not much but it's something you can
you can play so we five Izzy five a
problem okay i'll just play f3 and King
f2f ego ce5 okay yeah my capture so this
is the possible weakness the spawn if I
take it for it's not easy to attack
really okay i can i can i can try this
trying to provoke f5 and then I played
reform with listen with this idea yeah
but shouldn't this be quite nice for me
I can I can play this forced and down
now take the ideas to play to play b5
attacking on the queenside okay so maybe
he wants to play the beep on himself as
possible
should I play maybe before yeah let's
play b5 and king before immediately
attacking if you press B 6 update c6 and
capture next move yeah maybe I can just
play a king be 60 King be 67 look Sam oh
it gives no media file now try it for a
counter play with the H horn okay I just
I just want this pawn yeah I can ignore
that I think just push the C porn yeah
but that's the last I'll have another
beer pong it should really be too much
yeah alright so in my seven games yeah
thanks i accept okay i wanted to play
you five really let's try to get from
them kind of head shop set up often this
is so nice and those house time control
games because you can play so quickly
okay this is weird g3 and then then
playing should be three all right yeah
I'm not sure I should really take on c3
but dumb doesn't look too healthy but
he's threatening e5 so hmm maybe I need
to and now play d 697 yeah the d6 ponnam
could be a problem obviously but his
so many pieces on the default yeah maybe
I should have taken your form it is
hanging after all yeah but yeah def let
us d3si and this really wants lots of
stuff without any obvious some
compensation I hope be five or does this
weekend too much I plan may be here and
yeah let's just check the Queen and rock
the eight next move try to get rid of
the rock should be enough really oh the
back rank this will cost lots of
material now yeah I'll just win the
Queen iam all right mmm this game is not
starting yeah maybe time to grab a glass
of water yeah those technical problems
with games not starting and such really
am improved recently here on chess cube
but now this arrow is coming up again
yeah
don't know yeah try to say it dot the
game again so yeah I'm patient well not
so much but what can you do okay this is
actually a game yeah this is a bit
questionable would want to have a
sharper position he form might be a
problem at least them at a later stage
try to play okay might be form maybe I
should just play this and this way try
to distract him want to get the night
tune e60 e61 up like this yeah Queen
side looks a bit shaky oh he allows that
just like that I was thinking how to how
to get him to move the night oh yeah
take the Queen yeah was even thinking
about the g5 or something to get the
night away but you moved it down just
like that
yeah he simply ignored this this night
sacrifice okay ah this is actually a bit
too complicated for two minute game you
know about this is the sauna I like now
this just seems like some attack going
if it takes yeah right I need to eat to
play this very directly hmm guy just
play some any kind of move without any
specific idea you could have calculated
taking or something what is just playing
something immediately to just be quick
yeah I've quite quite a nice
compensation here obviously but it's not
not so easy without the time constraint
yeah white now is probably close to
winning so but well look at the time
yeah so completely completely winning
this position but you need to manage
manage on the clock Erica fade now
decides but ten seconds
oh this was close well but considering
the position I certainly did you
deserved all right yeah I'm not really
really quick I don't know sometimes so
you just slow with your hands I don't
know what this is I haven't played any
games before so to sort of get into the
flow and this really felt like a bullet
game it would like two minutes or
something I spent so much time at the
beginning to refute the setup or try to
refute it cannot really tell if I
managed all right we got some v6 type of
position not sure looks pretty decent
for white maybe can play Bishop i have
three also okay this i don't mind so
much at some fairly close now white
certainly being a bit better but um
shouldn't be shouldn't be a huge problem
hmm yeah well maybe it is cannot do much
especially i'm developing promise with
my development maybe i can somehow try
to provoke him to move on the queenside
but down yeah c5 is a constant problem
I tried to play a form okay let's try
this maybe he closes the position nope
yeah this is also better I think we're
closing the position yeah i got this am
somewhat strangely position position
tonight on a six this is a problem maybe
I can play Bishop f5 and then 97 okay if
it takes me six what would also go back
can't really protect it maybe can play
be 79 yeah he did this hmm yeah
sometimes it's amazing what kind of
moves people find even with a really low
rating sometimes they just play
brilliant moves all right maybe I can
somehow get this pawn back now I'm down
to 22 seconds good to know we just need
to speed up now no matter about the
position just don't try to be quick
Sam not really quick yeah no idea
sometimes they just play brilliantly
even with a terrible rating all right so
this is one of the better the better
players in this tournament right h5 is
so quite a decent line and somehow I'm
not even on leading by far don't know
sometimes it's just weird winning all my
games quickly and still some some other
guys are just as fast or whatever so G
for winning the light or is there some
brilliant trick now to justify this um
nope I can even cover it I think this
night still doesn't have any squares
okay can i play a magnet just I was as
was intending night to move the light to
be five but yeah maybe this is just just
too complicated really unnecessary right
okay let's exchange Queens should should
win relatively relatively easily at
least in a normal time controlled
situation I'm not so sure about this
time time no seeum I just landed the
Beatle Paul I'm just that just an idiot
yeah this law immediately is good for
black with a stupid Bishop b5 coming
amazing amazing yeah this is so just
lost now this position from this was
completely ridiculous game ok I can I
can resign that yeah he just blundered
apiece and yeah okay
everything winds basically 95 probably
wins also I mean alright so let's
continue I am still on phone first place
but the tournament could have been
basically over already all right yeah
not quite sure what white is doing here
with this f3 and one gave me this
picture but while I was so pleased at
the game before alright still leading by
20 something points yeah tons each again
is a pretty good fighting player it's
dangerous and tactics yeah I'm just
trying to play normal developing moves
try to get a solid simple position yeah
this is now quite nice for white with a
g5 and f5 plate I should have a very
nice square on 85 coming yeah maybe not
chief also
yeah if he captures the night I would
have just taken with the jeep on all
right so let's let's cover this first
don't want to take it then you can can
take with the pawn and yeah it's not so
easy still
yeah I'm not so sure about this movie I
should play this dark squares getting
weak yeah so cannot really take yeah his
f4 night is also not bad yeah still it's
a time issue is he's just playing
everything instantly and trying to win
on time basically so I'm not really
playing playing for any kind of position
all right
yeah so it's not easy and um I was very
slow obviously what we had game at
sometimes it's really hard to understand
chess he played really am utmost utmost
bad with the g5 and but I certainly
didn't take any advantage of this yeah
this is just lost now and I was too slow
this is really really interested me what
I would what I played wrong there who's
g5g five this is so this is really weird
and um yeah well need to play the next
game yep to come on be eight strangely
enough with this bishop so just just a
bit strange everything I'll just develop
me to be cautious about the rock yeah
maybe I can go here Fisher basics
preventing his castling while really it
should be rather nice okay let's grab
the look first maybe there was something
else but should be enough really
just attacking the night I could have
taken it fit in one move also just with
the bishop okay yeah I'm still on the
lead still are playing a rather badly
this game I lost with against charged
with G 595 so don't understand what
happened alright so can't come here
panel for tech we get to the well-known
endgame variation need to play e6 now or
Knight b6 yeah oh this I never saw is
possible night two before really I don't
know never saw this move only no night
XD form
yeah it certainly cannot yeah what about
is a is only cannot play this um I'll
just take d7 ok maybe here doesn't
matter really I just takes c6 now and
I'd win this ok so you should be 5 rupee
one maybe this is the quickest but okay
just just developing should be should be
ok also so no made here looks a lot like
some some checkmate should be possible
but yeah this is certainly certainly ok
let's threaten Bishop g5 or whatever
nighty form everything then this a made
somehow come on and Queenie for medium
alright this is nice alright so leading
but the way I'm playing it doesn't mean
much yeah beat this a bit the sky reform
yeah some reversed kind of vino me here
ok yeah this is just just a pawn for
nothing what doesn't have any kind of
compensation
okay just likes the view porn position
would be okay with the beep on but yeah
I points upon what can you do okay I try
to get some pieces towards the king
maybe join what I can just give this
check now you cannot capture because of
the pin yeah well I did capture with it
just an extra Queen now now hide the
shape okay let's play Keith well maybe
I'm a bit quicker in this kind of kind
of position then with III I was informed
i mean of course yeah this already paid
off this is a nice already got it
possible attack brewing on the Kings
side with 95 want to go nigh g5 next if
he allows me to do so okay oh I'll do
this now no h7 should just fall I place
94 which is also not too great I can
even take on f7 right ya think so
yeah but Queen h5 isn't this a bit much
push-up g6 now queen edge a checkmate
looks very difficult to defend and also
of course I can also take everyone to
make it just in exchange yeah this one
could take or can I can take first and
let's check f1 first come on it's a he
cannot save the piece here anyway keep
it simple so take now and now Bishop g5
maybe yeah should be ok ok let's take
the rook and now attack g7 should really
win the house its first yeah maybe I
overlooked some kind of quicker made
don't know this is quite ok
yeah still leading 32 points yeah this
is helpful oops so X this was a gown
fourth place just resigning al que se is
about 28 games he's playing the strategy
of resigning immediately if you feel
that you don't have so much so good
chances and and he pushes all the other
games it just resins against the better
players and tries to beat the weaker
ones yeah the Scottish four nights yeah
of course this is not really solid but I
want to try try to win quickly and it's
it's better than it looks this kind of
stuff now each 5h for is the idea on e5
md5 okay he wants to exchange maybe I
can play five and now trying to play on
the edge file if he exchanges it doesn't
okay now I see let's play 94 not a bad
idea really okay not much I can do what
I can drop 20 kf3 would be nice
yes so have play here against the F to
pawn I mean I want to oh no I can just
take it threatening discoveries now and
also see too yeah this is like how many
extra pawns five I know quite quite a
lot and I control the a the a1 square so
an important square which the pawn will
who queen yep simply not resigning yeah
this would have been a stalemate still
need to look all right 72 points now
this looks quite good okay young one guy
with more than 100 points yeah let's
play normal here normal stuff no Queens
pawn screen Paul openings this Bishop g5
or so just normal Kings Indian
well now taking all that five plus also
okay all right I'll just take this
animal porn up for don't know not much I
guess yeah long-term plan is not to open
the queenside what is giving me another
pawn I sometimes I simply don't
understand the kind of idea maybe now
wants to sec I don't know where to get
anywhere I'm just covering all these
pawns and then three pawns up or
something it's got what 45 m three
points up yet I forgot all eight pounds
okay so what now g5 yeah the main
problem is that every move wins
basically they don't don't know which
one you should play so trying for Bishop
H okay I don't know what's happening
here I just take everything
I don't know I simply don't understand
what's going on I'm sorry he's just
sacrificing everything and my king is a
bit shaky it's not not completely easier
something at least in a two minute game
yeah but now should this be rather
rather easy to win I what neat-o lie to
lie to F or something I want to look on
the g4 which Bishop f7 I droop g8 it's
the idea should win the Queen okay and
somehow survive this could quadruple
fonseca whatever so I'm it's nine
minutes to go and have rather rather
huge lead it wasn't so strong this time
and I think most people are doing what
you actually should do on a hot day at
least I out day in Europe I don't know
other places might be different but lots
of people here are from Europe anta it's
I'm out here and at least in most
countries okay so I've consumed some
kind of isolated pawn position I Drive
would be six maybe this is a bit too
ambitious but ok I think I think it's
okay you might have had some chances to
try to refute this bus with a quick
Bishop c4 or something like that this
looks nice now I've got quite some some
pressure on deform lighter so nice on 85
yeah he wants to play Bishop a
three-year yeah should I take you three
and don't know maybe just exchange
Queens shouldn't be too bad I have to
see file and still a fairly solid
position with his pawn as a natural
weakness that I can attack look on the
seventh and now I try to fix his pawn
some dark squares and you smoking maybe
to c6 you came to c 6 and yeah okay I
don't mind that it's still a good Bishop
against this a good night against this
Bishop one
all pawns on light squares yeah and now
I should take the chance for a five okay
okay I'll take the pawn with an extra
point it really should be a rather
simple win try to play h yep each for
grabbing more material only issue again
I don't think you can trap the night set
up upon yeah if it takes an OB to be two
queens alright got 60 points ahead it
should be enough really um I think of
very dangerous sounding name yet don't
want the exchange again let's play okay
now I exchange with the awful night on d
7 I would like that yeah I want a try
for some kingside play Queen f32 to h3
something like this maybe i can i can
even play play the sound more directly
okay I want to play you for this is the
idea opening up the center okay I need
to cover this first
95 eyes got 95 whoops this was too quick
it's got 95 I completely overlooked 95
mm okay it's not even a nap in now oh my
god don't tell me I'm spoiling this
tournament with the silly game now I
just I just played this far too quickly
it's really obvious that it's not
working okay yeah okay need to somehow
muddy the waters here it's hard to do
he's gotta maybe i can i can try this
it's hard to do really he's got them
fairly solid position I just got two
points i did haha i thought i had three
already okay this is really a game wish
I deserve to lose it's not like I played
badly also count wrong okay we are still
trying to continue I could have taken f7
I'm just just an idiot he just gives me
this Bishop alive
yeah yeah I'm gaining a bit here just a
bit bit of activity it's so the wrong
colored bishop also i think this is a
draw now objectively it's a draw yeah at
the time yeah oops okay now it is it
wrong oh what a crap game what a crap
game um and this guy came close 14
points and I I know ever managed to get
a game in it would be heartbreaking I'm
playing badly but stopped at the last
minute would be really really awful so
let's try to get a really quick gamin
it's a french exchange of all openings
when you want a quick win
come on take on f6 or something I'm
still on first place but this is all
getting terribly tricky he might be able
to to get him another Gaiman I'm just
wondering a five no really really
getting irritated here towards the end
of the tournament ah and this guy's on
minus 11 yeah minus 11 what the heck am
i doing and what is he doing now it's
just I thought I was briefly thinking
it's like I'm letting the clock run down
yeah I'm just I'm just a piece down
nothing more nothing less and in six
seconds did I make it it's over what's
happening now five the first place well
oh man I know if this was deserved at
this terrible last game and whatever he
didn't manage to get another game in so
I wanted at the end yeah very mixed kind
of tournament some some okay games and
some some really bad ones yeah help you
got entertained
anyway thanks for watching